you know it takes me back to the notion
of belief and gossip like the whole
reason why Humanity has been so
successful and spread through so many
continents is because of Gossip
essentially you know you know the reason
I don't have a $20 bill here but but if
I held up a $20 bill the the only reason
why that we all agree that it's worth
$20 is because we all agree that it's
worth $20 if there if there was a large
contingence of the population said it's
not worth anything you know I could wipe
my ass with but that's it and you know
we may get there one day we probably are
at some point with the way that fiat
currency is but um yeah you know like
you get the point right so if so
everybody in the family agrees with the
rule book then everything's going to be
fine but I think the problem that we
have like one of the issues you know I
was talking to a guy today on a private
console he's a very wealthy Uh Russian
immigrant and he was asking me about
some issues that he's got with um you
know his marriage and you know
potentially having kids and stuff like
that and um you know the notion that
Society culture Hollywood schools the
education system like everything out
there screens you know like parents are
giving kids screens at five six seven
years old now you go to a restaurant you
sit down they don't even parent their
kids or talk to them or engage them it's
put a screen down headphones and they
stare at it and that's how they parent
right so we've got all of these
influences and even if you're a good
parent you don't give your kids a screen
you put them in the school system the
school system is going to introduce
rainbows pronouns Oh Billy you feel like
a girl today let's call you Sally no
problem right like you know you're going
to have all of these things
indoctrinated into your children so you
really don't even own your own children
unless you're in a small community or a
compound and people have tried that
people have tried that you know we saw
what happened with Ruby Ridge dude just
want to go to the top of mountain and be
left alone government wouldn't [__]
leave him alone you know we saw what
happened at Waco you know slightly
different you know scenario but he
wanted to have his little compound sort
of thing going on right like we see
these these efforts to sort of draw a
perimeter
around us to keep them and their
influences away and it doesn't really
seem seem to work right that's why I I
still more or less you know subscribe to
the decline is real enjoy it
right I just I don't think that does
anything beneficial for civilization as
a whole especially those of us with
children I got two young daughters and I
want to try to create at least this have
a daughter as well for sure then I want
to create for my daughter and for you
know children that you have a slightly
better place where they could live that
it's less confused and I think the
Alterna important to save the world than
it is to save your own Inner Circle like
the people that you care about well
that's that's that's what I was getting
to is like also too with the
indoctrination piece is like my wife
doesn't work we're going to be
homeschooling our children we're going
to create a community within our
community we're not talking about like
an Amish compound that would be ideal of
course but I know you know the state
wants its hands or the province whatever
want that you know they want their hands
in your business to a certain degree we
have to exist within the system that has
been created as corrupt as it is the
laws and the government and it goes back
to a point that I get slammed about is
like listen men inherently are built for
risk and the risk is worth the reward
and so and this is where it goes back to
proper biblical courtship too because a
lot of the failures of the divor of
divorces and marriages are because men
and women aren't going into marriage
with a sober mind is that rich you know
I know I've had a you know degenerate
past you can't paint uh red flags green
bro and so approaching the courtship
process and not having sex until you're
married red flag okay but what but what
about the whole notion of repentance
though like doesn't that paint a red
flag green no what I mean what I mean by
that is if by engaging in in premarital
fornication premarital sex you kind of
confuse yourself so you can't actually
really see the person for who they are
and I've certainly been in relationships
before my wife or I was like I was I
thought I had this like this type of
woman in front of me when really I was
just in a state of euphoria because I
was addicted to the the intimate side
and so if more men approach this with
okay I want to really see who this woman
is I'm not going to engage in the sexual
you know um Behavior with her really see
who she is that's going to give you that
much better of a chance and a leg up
going to marriage of course is it
perfect no but when you combine
Christian values following you know
Christ in the Bible and the church and
doing it this way I mean it certainly is
going to lower your chances and to me
the risk is worth the reward if that
means go ahead okay I got another point
over here I wanted to bring up as well
um somebody on that space said that they
either if I touch on that at some point
yeah go ahead Chase go
ahead so dude you raised so many really
good points just then uh particularly
around the subversion of of the family
by all these outside forces and we kind
of we kind of ended on a black pill of
well you know the whole ship is going
down might as well enjoy it while we can
the Christ pill for me see here's the
thing man I think the black pill is more
of a nihilistic View and a
hate yeah I mean there's well there is
niil there's a lot of hate and
resentment towards women and even guys
that are doing [__] with their life from
the black pill community
yeah I I I I I'm not referring
necessarily to the black pill Community
if that is a community I don't know it's
I'm just using it colloquially like when
somebody's blackpilled like they're
hopeless
and um you know I I I reject the
nihilistic perspective because when I
when I look at us as men and what we
were created by God to do right Mike
obviously knows in Genesis uh God
commanded man to rule over and subdue
and govern the Earth right we were
created to govern the Earth God uniquely
equipped us to be the rulers of this
world and to rule the world under God's
headship he also commanded us to be
fruitful and multiply and we're told
throughout the scriptures to raise our
kids in the way of the Lord and if you
do that you know they won't depart from
it in their old age if you do it
properly I'm big on the idea of
Christian patriarchy rich like my my
goal for my life what I really want to
do is have as many kids as I possibly
possibly can I want to raise them in the
way of the Lord and I I I want to build
a legacy and a dynasty in this world
where my future Generations will go on
to continue to spread the gospel of
Christ and to work against these forces
of darkness and reorder Creation in the
way that it's meant to be ordered where
things aren't so freaking degenerate the
best way to do that is well I think so
many children what' you say what do you
think the best way to do that is to have
so many children to make that happen why
do I think or what do you think the best
way to do that is because I mean like
the Christian you know perspective seems
to be one man one woman but there's um
you know guys out there that have
multiple wives that have multiple
children with them right yeah you're
fighting an uphill battle if you want to
beat up the Muslims because they're
taking on multiple that's why Christians
got to have more babies we gotta have as
many as man you gotta have more wives
then so here's the thing about that I
used to be big into this idea earlier in
my 20s Rich after I got into the red
pill there's a lot of lot of dudes in in
the sphere that were're talking about
polyamory or polygon polygon is what
it's called I I used to be big into that
idea and I was like man you know I never
want to get married I just want to make
a ton of money and have like 10 W 10
women that I have like three kids with
each have like 30 kids that sounds legit
yeah which sounds really cool when
you're like 23 years old and full of
piss and vinegar and then like the
reality of life and how complicated it
is starts to set in and it's like wow
that's uh very difficult to manage right
can you imagine managing 10 women
freaking job and I I started I started
to look throughout the Bible in my in my
walk with Christ I I I would I would
read throughout the Bible and there's
Patriarchs all throughout the Old
Testament that would have multiple women
and they would have children with
multiple women and the pattern that you
notice over and over again is that
departure from the one man one woman
model often creates Bloodshed and strife
and fighting between their kids right
because you have a man who is committed
to multiple women classic
example uh you've got Abraham promised
children by God promised to be the
father of Nations he decides to take
matters into his own hands and he sleeps
with his wife's servant Hagar instead
and has ishmail he he does not have
faith in God's promise he has ishmail
and then he has Isaac after the fact
well that sin one of the products of
that sin the prophet Muhammad is a
descendant of Ishmael If Abraham had not
departed from God's promise and and and
what he was supposed to do just with his
one wife we would not have a war in our
current world today between Christianity
and Islam uh King David King Solomon
they took multiple wives God commanded
them not to their children fought they
fought for the kingdom they wor other
what' you say or or were killed in sort
of like God's Wrath King David right
before Solomon was born right yes and
and I look at that with your model then
if I understand it correctly you need
every guy to man up and take the Christ
pill and every woman to man up and woman
up and take the Crist pill and just
start going forth and being fruitful and
multiplying dude if we had if we could
create a culture Rich where people
earnestly pursued biblical gender roles
and had as many children as possible
with one another and properly raise them
in alignment with Biblical values if if
every man and woman in the west or let's
just say let's say 10% of the men and
women in the west did this and they each
had five to six kids each within five
generations we could fix literally
everything that is going wrong in the
world ev Everything could be fixed if we
stuck to this
model that's the most ideal scenario
obviously the most ideal scenario I me
that would that would assume that they
that the kids uh world viiew and belief
system wouldn't be polluted by Mo modern
culture and society which is going to be
very very hard to do because they seem
to be winning that battle
overwhelmingly well and I think that
begs the question of who is pushing this
degeneracy but that's a conversation for
another podcast you can just look at the
leaders of our respective countries Joe
Biden and Justin Trudeau like this like
this is who people vote
for yes but I'm speaking to something
deeper who who who controls the flow of
information and the flow of ideas and
where where is that stream originating
from that's an interesting question but
uh we don't we don't have nearly the
amount of control that we think that we
do no we don't stuff like that but a man
has control over his household and what
the the stuff that his children cons he
does absolutely to a degree right and
that's why if I may just add one more
thing Rich okay I want to go to the sex
point after that yeah that that's why
biblical p strong biblical patriarchy
strong male leadership within the
household creating a strong biblical
culture within the household is so
important because that bleeds down
through generations and you have to
create that tradition raise your sons
well to be biblical Patriarchs raise
your daughter daughters well to be
prepared for that that role as mothers
and wives you know like that that kind
of culture so important and it protects
against degeneracy over time I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out